all right in minnesota they had an
experience this year with a quarterback
who was drafted without the incumbent
getting a heads up now it wasn't round
one it was round three it wasn't a trade
up kellenbond fell to them after the
buccaneers made kyle trask the final
selection of round two there's kyle
monde early round three the vikings make
the move monde at rookie mini camp this
weekend talking about what he's doing to
get himself ready for life in the nfl
pretty quick after i got drafted i got
my ipad and so i've already i've already
watched all the 20 20 games and you know
really watched them multiple times and
just um some plays are a little bit more
advanced that you know i necessarily
haven't gotten to you know we're still
on you know pretty pretty a lot of the
base stuff on install
but it's still a lot of information so
still be able to watch kirk on certain
cut ups
and certain certain things that i really
enjoy and
just really enjoy uh just watching his
execution watching his footwork and just
watch how he he's able to um you know
just go through reads and pretty much
master the offense so um you know the
more i watch him the more i'm able to
kind of mimic you know his footwork
his cadence which is huge in the nfl so
i mean there's there's so much uh so
many things that i need to learn and but
you know i feel like i'm in a phenomenal
organization
with phenomenal talent and
you know obviously can't wait to get to
work with kirk also
that quote created an obvious headline
that he's trying to mimic kirk cousins
which prompted how'd you feel about that
how'd you feel about it don't well when
you see the full explanation it makes
sense right when you see the annoying
headline at pft
that's when that's when you say why are
you trying to but look hey
kirk cousins has strengths
kirk cousins has weaknesses they're both
well established and to the extent that
there are things that cousins does well
and kellen monde can study those on film
and do those things he will be better
off for it in the offense that kirk
cousins runs the things where kirk
cousin has weaknesses those are inherent
athletic limitations helen mon doesn't
have those right helen monde can take a
play that goes to hell and not just
crumple in the pocket or throw the ball
away or begin to run away from pressure
and get gobbled up before he can even
get three feet from where he was
standing looking for a receiver that's
why the vikings have moved in this
direction and they need protection
against the fact that cousins is under
contract for two more years and they've
got no way to keep him after 2022 they
would have been unprepared for what
comes next if they didn't look for a
quarterback and you know i continue to
hear they were looking at justin fields
who was in the process of falling to
them at 14 and when the bears traded up
to get fields that forced them to move
to plan b and they're happy with kellen
maude and i got no problem with him
studying kirk cousins he's got to learn
he's got to learn the nfl game and he's
got things that could make him
better than kirk cousins right but first
he's got to figure out the things kirk
cousins does well that's right i mean
yes he has more high-end talent than
kirk cousins kirk cousins is still
really damn good starting nfl
quarterback there's a lot to learn and
and really every rookie quarterback for
the most part you know if has any
veteran in front of them that has any
you know established part of their
career you do mimic them the coaching
staff tells you to mimic them it's just
a good base like starting point for a
rookie quarterback you know when i was a
rookie i got in there brad johnson was
the guy yeah i mimicked him because the
way he was doing things right as far as
executing the offense oh okay he took a
seven step drop and then he took one
hitch step and then moved to the reed
second read okay that's you know so
that's where cousins is a machine as far
as doing things right to your point
within the confines of the offense you
know footwork body positioning for each
read all of those type of things reading
and reacting to the defense and that's
where like hey kellan mon he certainly
can learn some things from kirk cousins
and that that aspect cousins is amazing
at
reading coverages and
you know at that point just reacting and
pulling the trigger to throw the
football almost seamlessly is really one
of his great strengths and now you get a
guy like monde who's smart and i think
can read defenses the same way but like
you said has more high-end talent that's
when maybe you can groom something
special here so it is a positive that
he's mimicking kirk cousins and i know
kirk cousins isn't a top five
quarterback in football but damn he's
done a lot of good and uh either way
headline reality whatever i'm okay with
him mimicking cousins at this point
how do you think cousins reacts to the
situation he seems to be very aware of
the business side of the game we had him
on pftpm the week before the super bowl
he made it clear he's got no interest in
extending his current contract he wants
to play it out that gives him all the
leverage going into 2023 and i think
he's mature enough to understand the
vikings did have to protect themselves
but having that that that presence
that that alternative other than sean
mannion
how does that affect kirk cousins as a
as a player knowing that if it all goes
sideways they at least have somebody
else they can trot out there and see
what he has i don't think it's going to
affect him at all at this point i really
don't i think he's too much of a robot
he's too you know
into the details of the offense and
making himself better and just played
too much football to where i don't think
you can really infiltrate his brain to
where it's going to really throw him for
a side track you know side track him at
all at least you know this is a guy
again he's kind of been through it all
as far as this is concerned you know he
took over in washington everybody wanted
him off the field and rg3 back in there
you know then he did take over and he
played and it was always like get him
out of here then you know you like that
you like that and all that stuff
happened and the contract and the
pressure that situation you know i just
don't think he's gonna really blink at
it i don't you know he's a very aware
like you said uh but i think he's too
obsessed with his own craft to be really
worried about some of the outside
factors and things like that so i don't
expect any slippage from kirk cousins
and his play this year at all
and i guess the best news for the
vikings they got a third round rookie
quarterback who is already in there
busting his butt and that was the one
thing that impressed me about kellenbond
you talked to him i talked to him a week
or so after that he seems like a guy who
is going to
to go all in go all in and he's going to
be all football all the time i asked him
the question you know if you weren't
playing football what would you be doing
with your life and he it's not even on
his radar screen his life's been all
about football and that's his motivation
and uh he he's gonna throw himself into
it and yeah and make it his whole
existence
is is that a healthy balance i don't
know but the reality is if you want to
be among the best in the nfl you've got
to surrender your life to it that's the
tom brady approach you got to be willing
to work harder than me because i am
going to put everything i have in it and
that that that's a necessary
prerequisite to being great you're not
just going to roll out of bed and be
great not in today's nfl no you're not
and especially not a quarterback you
know
you might be able to get away with it at
some points but quarterback i don't
really care
you know how talented you are it's just
it's a position like listen mahomes we
see him he's as talented as we've ever
seen in the sport we know he's all in
he's all in same with rogers it's just
if you want to be great if you want to
play a sustained amount of time have a
career
it has to consume you in all facets i
mean i i grew up around a guy where i
saw it consume him i tried to take the
same approach in my career every it has
to be your life it's too short of a
career and then there's two you got to
be able to
there's too many other circumstances
that affect you
so you need to be at your absolute best
if you want to make it work that's the
biggest thing you know you got coaches
bad players good players you know good
coaches bad owners good it's too many
things that can affect your play to
where you want to make sure the one
thing that's constant is i'm
all in tip-top ready to go in all facets
and that's what an nfl quarterback has
to be to be successful
yeah and uh um that's just the reality
of life in today's nfl and calendar
beginning that crash course studying
kirk cousins in the good way calm down
vikings fans it's actually good news not
bad news and and you know we have fun
with kirk cousins has done some great
things at quarterback in the nfl yes but
there are limitations and also
the vikings as i said need to be
protected contractually because one
thing he's done as well as anyone is
he's worked that system to his advantage
and he's made a load of money
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports